at more and more conventions they
arrived people are unexpected unaware
they are angry depraved and Savage they
often go unnoticed at first but soon
everybody is aware of their existence
they cause more and more trouble
everywhere they go and it simply looks
like there is no end in sight these are
disgruntled lives hated by all
especially themselves the disgruntled
mimes only goal is to reach havoc and
chaos everywhere he comes and by God are
they annoying number the promised Molly
take I like to know a lot of people
think you know that we choose to be this
way lightweight like this is the way we
want be like it's a lifestyle choice but
but it's not I mean it it's just one of
those things you know we're walking
around we didn't want get chops and some
I'm on this tree and said hey nobody
would willingly do that without getting
paid a lot of money so mm-hmm and we can
take a being to that always helps we can
see behind us and we know you're there
oh I'm sorry she disappeared
a giant family use disassembly turned
into a fam we're used to seeing walls
that aren't really there
you can see everything we've been kicked
out of France so many times that they
don't even let us on the plane well the
last time we were there it's like they
don't even appreciate us anymore you
know we got five croissants shoved up my
ass
they still love Jerry Lewis but oh yeah
yeah so don't mess with Jerry oh yeah
mm-hmm
that's a shepherd mm-hmm Jerry Lewis and
Ben sighs seems to be the only thing
they're like over there crease exactly
see I'm in a wall
the BioPark refresh it's nice in here I
don't have my damn kids the beatings are
hard that they're hard to take
I gotta be honest but at the same time
no there's no saying that they're hard
and they saw well you go about them a
different way I went at it at the way of
putting on 80 pounds of solid fast-food
weight as mark cushions everything as a
stereotype okay the mindscape are racist
against mine Cargill next time there's a
Klansman be right
the idea that minds don't talk is a
stereotype now what what you think we
don't have tongues yeah you know you
think we can't verbalize what we say
that maybe we have nothing to say and if
we're trapped inside of something and we
are in danger why would we not speak up
it makes no sense it makes no sense to
be entrapped in a closed space in a
sinking boat and not yell for help
sometimes I have this theory I believe
hard enough I put my hotel key in my
fake hotel key it'll open but never
fucking works next time my friend next
time next time
god I hate the concrete we've been
practicing our crap
this is me in a box oh my god
educated the business okay do you know
how to train late night to go through to
make myself believe I was in that box
oh it's a box cool for years man you big
grapevine because you really can't talk
you haven't said that people think you
just say you know I'm trapped inside a
box as that's not how it works you have
to believe you're in the box oh yeah
mm-hm and a lot of times I do sometimes
I don't but the great thing is that what
I do when I don't you can't tell you
know because I'm that good it's
interesting to do this for a living and
also be legitimately claustrophobic
it makes the terror more real mm-hmm and
it gives us something to talk about with
our therapist that's true mm-hmm give me
something
would you excuse me for that be trippin
never guy oh yeah that was Keanu Reeves
with MIT I think so yeah and where is
this magic part where we're standing
this is right I feel way too so close
now we don't just do this for the money
that's not what this is about at all cuz
god I do it for the money yeah so do I
yes money and the tits are nice now a
lot of people are probably like well how
do you see tits or mine and stuff you
know you can't possibly seem a tip but
the fact of the matter is is that there
are women out there who love us they
will just be walking down the street and
we can go up to them and give them money
and they they they can't get enough of
us you know they even take us back to
their hotel room what you don't want to
get into any ungentlemanly details but I
will just say there is a significant
amount of scantily clad let's call them
Street walkers okay get enough of what
we do I think those are hookers
that I'm in love with a beautiful gaggle
of hookers hi I know your mom's awesome
we do stuff like this elevator except
it's not real
grace is fucked
a lot of people say that we are the
worst minds ever and my answer to that
is at least we're the best at something
even if it's being the worse a lot of
people can't be the best isn't they and
we've succeeded exactly and if we were
just mediocre no one remembers that oh
you're gonna remember the best and
you're definitely gonna remember the
worst right the image of us is gonna be
burnt into your head until the day you
die in your nightmares every minute of
every day I feel like I'm going to be
murdered but I've gotten used to it just
like I've got used to a pogo stick and
shoved up my ass I have a guy just
looking back on everything that we've
done the experience everything we've
gone through the hard work dedication
everything what do we do it again no no
no no no no no no no no no no yeah I
would go back to school and get a job
and no white children